now to a story a lot of people are
talking about colorado's governor is
under growing pressure to reduce the
sentence of a truck driver who killed
four people in a fiery crash his name is
rohel aguilera medeiros he was sentenced
to more than a hundred years in prison
last week his truck plowed into a line
of vehicles on interstate 70 that's just
outside of denver this was back in 2019.
mark straussman looks now at the
mandatory minimum sentencing laws that
have inspired a nationwide petition for
leniency in this particular case
i'm begging for forgiveness
twenty-six-year-old rohel aguilera
medeiros sobbed in court when he was
sentenced last week to 110 years in
prison on four counts of vehicular
homicide and 23 other charges i'm crying
all the time when i'm thinking about it
four people were killed in this fiery
wreck on colorado's interstate 70 in
april of 2019.
it's a steep road in the rocky mountain
foothills aguilera madero says his
brakes failed but video shows he may
have missed a runaway truck ramp where
prosecutors claim he could have pulled
off he made a series of terrible
decisions aguilera medeiros received all
minimum sentences but because colorado's
law requires them to be served
consecutively it added up to 110 years
something even the judge objected to if
i had the discretion
it would not be my sentence as of this
morning more than four and a half
million people have signed a petition to
reduce aguilera medeiros sentence
colorado governor jared polis said his
office has received a clemency request
and he's reviewing the sentence gage
evans whose husband died in the crash
says sentencing laws should be reviewed
but the sentence itself should not be
commuted he was found
guilty of
reckless behavior that killed my husband
that was the most important thing to me
for cbs mornings i'm mark
how does he do it
i find it so tough these cases i mean
you feel for the families who lost
somebody but at the same time what does
taking away a fifth life do for the
whole situation i don't know and it's
110 years does seem extremely excessive
he says his brakes failed clearly he
made bad decisions if he didn't take the
route to go off when he could have 110
years also doesn't seem no prior
criminal record we need truck drivers in
this country it's it's a tough tough
case and for clarification laws are
different state to state yeah so
excessive in one state might not be in
another
it's unfortunate all the way around
that's for sure for everybody